this film sees you reunited with uh
lokite stanfield from get out
so yeah like when you're out and about
people must have loved it seeing the two
of you together again
yeah no yeah it was we went to a bowling
alley in cleveland because we shot in
cleveland
and then like people just coming up to
the cave doing
like flashing stuff and doing something
and i felt
like man i thought it just happened to
me i felt less alone i was like oh man
oh man you know that's cool that's cool
but like i kind of sometimes just sit in
the corner with my hat level and just
pretend
i don't exist to myself though so like
i try to keep in the shadows and stuff
so is it you rachel's watching how many
you've watched it
a few times two or three times yeah yeah
we loved it so much and i'm sure this is
the point of the film but we literally
sat there going
get out get out of there
you must get out yeah when i have
conversations now i have to say
leave leave
and like that film did so well i mean it
took hundreds of millions of dollars
around the world
but is it true that you and why did this
happen that you you didn't go to the
premiere you weren't invited to the
premiere no they they didn't invite me
bro
they didn't no that can't be true on the
sundance world premiere yeah
i was in atlanta because i was shooting
pamphlet i was shooting panther
and i was chilling and i was like i
cleared my schedule i was like you
already wanted it and then
just didn't they just didn't get an
invite man just didn't get it i didn't i
wasn't
i wasn't afraid so i was just in my bed
someone texts me it's gone really well
i'm like alright that's cool that's all
right
that's the industry graham no this is
the girl somebody [ __ ] up this come up
since then like have you asked them
about it
no no you don't if i don't ask questions
i just saw i get it man that's cool like
i i
like i'm very good i i would send a
stern
left-handed note
but you mentioned you mentioned black
panther there and i it
black panther ii am i writing that is
now happening
that's what the streets are saying groom
that's what the streets are saying yeah
okay which will be very exciting but
also
kind of tinged with terrible sadness
because of course chadwick boseman's no
longer with us
yeah yeah man it's you know
i don't even understand how like
it's gonna it's gonna we're gonna have
to honor him
you know honor him and honor give as
much to his
legacy as much as he gave to us because
he gave us everything
yeah you know stayed here to give us
everything and
like an incredible man an incredible
[Music]
soul